[Music]
my name is alicia thompson and i live in
woodward oklahoma
i'm a mother of four i started the
weight loss challenge on january 9th
and i weighed 240.6 pounds
dad passed away at the age of 46 um
41 years ago and i
decided that i didn't want to to
leave my kids without a parent like like
he did
a few weeks ago we took a weekend trip
with the kids and went down around
oklahoma city area
i was able to to go and stay up with
them all weekend
you know like all day saturday out in
the heat running
playing human foosball and you know then
all day sunday again and
i realized after i got home on monday i
was like
i wasn't tired once this weekend that's
kind of great
[Music]
i am at 198.0
so i've lost 42.6 pounds and it's pretty
amazing whenever you're excited to get
on the skills every morning and see what
the numbers are instead of dreading it
it's just kind of nice to to be able to
have the energy to
live a life like you should i don't
expect to be a twig at the end of this
because i've never been skinny my whole
life so um
you know that's not my goal is to see
how any i can get i just want to
want to see how healthy i can get so
that i can be around for a while
you really can't put a dollar amount on
the price of your life